foreign
[Music]
welcome to my talk and title limbs
enable biobanks ship ISO 20387
accreditation
first let's define what a biobank is
well buy a bank it's an laboratory
facility that accepts processes the
stores distributes samples in data for
use by research institutions
biobanks manage biological samples such
as blood tissue saliva plasma sales and
the related information and they can be
used by third-party research
institutions for research purposes for
example when they are development
treatments for several diseases or when
they are
studying genetic changes that may
increase the person's risks for several
illnesses like osteoporosis asthma or
some cancers the rule is to store these
Collections and to keep buy specimens in
a safe physical location while
maintaining quality so that researchers
can access them and the data associated
with this bio specimens
so to operate effectively biobanks need
trained and competent staff that is that
most follows predefined Sops to manage
and store samples while maintaining
their quality so buyable show maintain
sample records and documentation of all
biobanking activities for future
reference historical continuity on or
internal and external audits
so as I mentioned before buy a bag to
store several types of biological
materials but also so that your the data
derived from this biological material
and this data could be clinical history
this gives us information about the
patient and his Lifestyles also physical
exams with the doctor or some results
from laboratory studies they also store
demographics these can include the
gender the age ethnicity or geographic
location of the patient with donor also
family history this can degrade this
data the researchers can get health
information from the family of the
patient such as like for example the
parents or the grandparents of the
children and this is really important
for some research that it could use the
journalic and history for that
also they can store sample collection
procedures we did the researchers get
information about the preparation of the
patient also the collection processing
and storing of the specimen
the biobanks also are responsible for
managing for managing the informing
consent this type of consent is there so
important in clinical research to meet
establishes and compliances and the goal
of the informant concern is to enable
competent individuals to decide for
themselves whether to participate in
research or not
also biomass are responsible for
managing data safety and protection to
be able to share the information adhere
into International standards and
compliances
so as we can see diabetes play an
essential role in biomedical research
a library
research the time and resources needed
to recruit new participants for each
research to study are greatly reduced
because the samples and corresponding
medical information are available in
just one place so by making
sample collection and patient
recruitment more efficient better study
can be performed in a more timely manner
so research can just focus on the
research and not in recruiting patients
or looking for samples however
logistically speaking this could be a
nightmare because all samples in data
must be always kept safe and secure so
the staff must be capable of ensuring
their own safety and also to protect the
privacy of donors and to demonstrate
their competency
must comply with regulatory guidelines
another major challenge for Dubai events
is that the biology biological samples
are in most of them temperature
sensitive and may be affected by
environmental changes just like the
humidity light or the oxygen levels so
BuyBacks must build infrastructure and
employee monitoring systems to maintain
sample quality
so it is necessary also for buyer bags
to drag the samples through their life
cycle to avoid any problems like
misplacing them
so by complying with this standards such
as
iso20387 Dubai events can assure
someone's real quality integrity and
traceability through the sample life
cycle
so
now let's understand what is also 2387
and let's explore also the challenge
associated with this application
first what is iPhone well ISO is
International Organization for
externalization with publishes
International standards to maintain
quality safety and efficiency in a wide
range of Industries I saw recently
published a new standard specifically
for biops the iso 20387 in response to
the growing role of biobanks within the
life science Industry
requirements for all aspects of managing
biotecs including structural personal
facilities processes and equipment and
it also covers quality management system
them and have sample handling including
collection preservation transport
distribution and traceability of
biological materials and data numerous
standards around the world differ from
country to Country so and I saw a
marginalized these rules and allows
Laboratories and in this case the
biobanks to be evaluated under the same
standard
so now let's see why
isot20387 and why will biobanks want to
achieve it well the benefits of a buyer
Bank being accredited made any effort
worth as it promotes confidence because
iso20387 was developed to promote
confidence to buy events it is the same
system and clear
clear donors users and investors of its
capabilities
it assures that the biobank is taking
all reasonable measures to safeguard and
ensure that Santa's collected are being
used only for the intern problems also
ISO 203 is 7 ashures reliability in the
buyer Banks since researchers must
ensure that samples have been properly
stored and maintained throughout their
life cycle and ensure that the
experimental data coming from this
samples are reliable and can be
published in any Journal so they don't
have any doubt about the samples and
this process of the story
also accreditation provides valuable
information to the biobank on how it can
further improve or streamline its
process
potentially reducing costs cost and at
the same time accreditation potentially
improves efficiency minimizing process
errors
so now
the third question
will be how to achieve it well let's
start by saying that
iso20387 is most of the ISO standards
and informative it's pretty much
um really
um equal to some other Isis standards so
the section 4 contains the general
requirements for biopex the Clause 4.1
is about the general requirements this
is about the procedures addressing the
biobanking of each type of sample and
Associate data store also it includes
that the biobanks must document
information relevant to the activities
processes and procedures so they close
4.2 it's about the inertiality of the
staff the biobank will be the resultable
for the impertiality and shall not allow
that in general or external pressure to
compromise
because of 4.3 it's about
confidentiality this is the
confidentiality between the customers
and the biobanks and of course to the
staff and all the involved in the
biobank activities
the confidential information and
proprietary rights of the donors
recipients and users must be protected
by the biobank particularly during the
storage and transmission of data survive
them will
impound their privacy and their
confidentiality
so biobanks can take advantage of
informatic tools such as the biobanking
list just purely managed data
data a lens Forces Staff to authenticate
themselves using a two-factor
authentication mechanism a one-time
password and a password-based login for
secure access it opens up the staff
accounts temporarily on account for
multiple daily login attempts and well
this increase a lot of security when
handling confidential patients or donor
information
also to safeguard the protect health
information of patients and live
anonymized sensitive patient data and
assign role-based protect health
information access right to staff so the
substitute Mass data can be viewed only
by authorized persons and each time an
authorized person views or make any
changes to this protect health
information the activity is recorded in
the outer Trail so this is really useful
for audits because sometimes external
Auditors can request a protect health
information audit reports at any time
well let's talk about the section 5.
the fight is about structural and
organizational requirements this is all
about the staff and how they fit
together in a bioback it happens it has
several procedures to assure the staff
competence the Bible should specified
responsibility Authority and into
relationship of the personal to manage
perform validate or verify work affected
by a banking output so
the staff with the limbs can be granted
or revoked access to activities or
information based on the role in the
organization hierarchy and buy a bank
with limbs cannot find rights to stop
for accessing samples and donor
information based on the role we can see
here that the biobank manager has all
the rights to view create edit delete
and manage patients and Sample
information but other personal of the
staff only can view that information so
with a link buyer Banks can apply rights
to the staff for several activities
now let's speak about the section 6.
section 6 contains resource requirements
personal competence and training
requirements
is related to the training and
competence of your staff to manage side
effects it is self-confidence to develop
autobiobanking activities how
to take the
countries about facility
this includes
is dedicated to the biobanking
activities and monitoring environmental
conditions this is how the biosity and
biosecurity of the biological materials
and data are maintained also the
separation between areas to prevent
cross-contamination
the external processes it's about when
well it is when the biod banks decided
to use externally provide preservation
storing or authentication activities for
these external processes apply
and the equipment requirements a biobank
should be furnished with or have control
access to all equipment required for
biobanking this thought is all about the
traceability of your equipment when was
it celebrated when was the license
maintained which entropy was used well
how can I help to answer all this
questions
well to manage for example my personal
training a lamp ensures that only trains
per small handle biological assessments
data enhancers as chemicals and samples
in addition tasks can be assigned based
on the evaluate competencies we can see
here some training topics who was the
trainer who will be trainees and if
there was competent or not toxic so a
lamps can do all this for you
automatically
to manage external supplies a lens can
help to manage inventory items purchased
from external vendors and their current
quantities you can send with minor
alarms to the replenishment of inventory
items on time here we can see a list of
reagents and consumable we can see also
if they are expired or not and who is
responsible for them
and to manage equipment calibration and
maintains a limbs can help to track the
calibration and to manage the
maintenance data
the time for the next compression or
maintains enable managers to call the
technicians and have all the equipment
taken care of so your equipment will be
always up to date with the calibration
or the corresponding maintains
now let's see what ISO 2387 say on its
section 7. it is about prices
requirements so present requirements
since the collecting collecting our
biological materials and data it
includes recommend information
requirements well when buy events are
the responsible for collection
of the samples they shall Define and
document information related to this
collection most including plays and
procedural collection also this club
established that only qualified and
authorized personal show Collective
biological materials according to
defining processes
for the reception and distribution the
bivalent to established procedures for
accessing receiving and distributing
biological materials and data to their
customers
to transfer biological materials to data
the balance show maintain critical
change of capacity breakers for all the
biological materials and the data of the
customers too from point to dispatch to
foreign
and for traceability this is for the
specimens the Bible shall ensure
traceability of all the materials and
data throughout the last time
for the preparation and preservation
these are procedures that should be in
place for the preparation and
preservation of the biological status
how did you apply by performance
activity well in this Concepts
everything about it
sewage
how did you buy a Balance store the
sample for how long your diabet must
have procedures for this storage and
tracking of all the biological material
such as circus to uniquely it identifies
all the biological materials
the section 7 also includes quality
control of this materials and data the
body that must establish quality control
procedures related to critical activity
section 7 always also speaks about the
validation and verification of the
method the bioidential use validate or
verified measures for critical
activities at all stage of the
biological material life cycle this is
for example when you display samples
this must be carried out by a validated
and documented method and of course
doing by the frustrated person
section 7 also speak also speak about
the management of information and data
this was established that the Bible
should find the required information in
data related to the materials and shall
have a system in place for tracking
also speak about control of
non-conforming outputs these are
procedures for the management of outputs
that do not conform to the Sops of the
diabet so drovement should mitigate the
impacts of the non-conformity and
Implement corrective actions and present
a reference
also a report request required the
biogrant shot provide a report it must
include the required information as a
group of recipients so
any other way to report your results
this is the requirement that you should
take in account
and last it is the complaint this is
about to have the shared document and
employment procedures to receive
evaluate and make decisions on
complaints so to manage samples a lens
can help you to associate unique
barcodes with each sample enables you to
track the samples at any point in the
sample life cycle this is really helpful
because you always will know when where
is the sample and what barcode it has
so to maintain possibility limbs helps
you to maintain a trace log and track
changes made with a date and timestamp
along with the name of the person who
made the changes so you will have a
completely traceability of every sample
since it gets into your firebank since
it is distributed to the last customer
a lamps also can help you provide back
to mirror its storage inventory and
locate storage sample with is with this
you can see exactly where your samples
are located in which freezer in which
box
so also you can maintain a simple change
of custody of all samples or other Goods
through all the life cycle to regulate
their transfer from one custodian to
another the transfer can be internal or
external and a good link can show the
entire genealogy of the sample here you
can see a sample in group had it and to
whom it will transfer child capacity
with timestamp date stamp included
and the section A tell us about the
quantity Mass quality management system
requirements Dubai must have a quality
management system that can support and
demonstrate a consistent achievement of
the requirements of Business Center so
this section includes a clause for
documented information for its quality
management system so here the biobankmos
identified information that shall be
documented and ensure that the document
information is properly created and
updated
also it has uh for for quality control a
management system documents Revival must
control the document that related to the
format of this ISO 203 S7 how do you
control them also your control of your
records your biobank markets established
and maintain legible records and retain
records for accurate consistent with
this contractual and legal obligation
and the actions to address with an
opportunity the Bible must consider the
risks and opportunities associated with
their biomass activities and develops
implements and document actions plans to
mitigate such risks
Section 8 only also have a section for
the Improvement where the equality
management system and for the biobank
itself the Bible is most identified and
select opportunities for improvement and
Implement any necessary actions also for
correct actions and non-conforming
outputs what should be done if there is
a Phenom Conformity is an action
required how to decide well here are the
procedures for that internal audits all
the bioventions plan implements and
maintain an internal audit program
including the pregnancy methods
responsibilities planning and Reporting
and the quality management reviews
top management should review its quality
management system and plan
Eternal to ensure its continuous
effectiveness
so a good limbs manage all internal and
external documents content forms and
quality management manual
also tracks the revision history of each
document to ensure that the staff
members access only the latest version
it also provides role-based document
access rights to the staff providing
control access to the confidential
document
so let's list the benefits of having a
lens managing your biobank and how it
fits with the requirements of an ISO
20387 well I live a good limbs that
secures managed samples metadata and
donor concept assigned role-based access
to authorized users to save for preset
health information anonymize sensitive
patients say that the safeguards protect
health
the store Sops control documents and
records digitally and securely track
samples and maintain a chain of capacity
also manages staff training and
recompetency scheduled instrument
calibration and management maintains
data
maintain another Trail and force unto
authentication of Key activities through
digital signatures and optimize Reserve
management and Sample utilization
so let's see I buy a bank that was the
first
accredited under ISO 20387 it was the
coral Veterinary firebank this biobank
collects samples for from EU and healthy
animals and the samples are then
processed catalogs and provider
scientists around the world
they have a workflow that is most likely
like the one that I showed you on the
screen the sample collection acquisition
preparation preservation testing
analysis storage and distribution so
therefore the identification they
identify the relevant cases
and then when they identify the relevant
cases they make the the owners before
the collection the owners are in form of
the requirements for participation the
risk associated with the collection of
the of the samples and they give us
reaching consent for declaration the
source and distribution of the samples
so when they are collected they the
clinical team and technicians carefully
collect the blood or the tissue samples
and they are preserved appropriately to
ensure that they are fit for their
intent process so they then reduce there
is the registration the participants and
the samples are registered in a
buy-backing information management
system along with medical data such as
the spacious stage or clinical
Diagnostics so the information is they
identified to protect the privacy of the
owners and the animals and they are
given a unique ID like barcodes
so those samples are labeled with this
barcode and other necessary information
to ensure the traceability
then they process the laboratory team
classes they collected samples
and then our child for long-term storage
inappropriate conditions
so they receive the request of
evaluations and must include the
quantity type and specifications of the
samples to be requested as well as the
aim of the investigation so the requests
are evaluated and then
by using I'm sorry a biosystem in use
committee and once the request is
approved the buyer Banks withdraw the
sample from storage and processes as
needed
so then it's still delivery and the
samples are then delivered in person or
shipped to the recipient understate in
appropriate conditions so
as you can see quality management is
essential in dimensions and observation
of the biobank biovan should be able to
track each specimen and helps to manage
science specimens quality and the
effective use of the sample in the
future
so a good quality management plan can
lead to higher quality biased specimens
and reproducible research results so the
attention to detail it's a step of the
workflow needs to be documented
so now you have an action plan to meet
all the requirements of iso 203x7 and
accredited your file Bank you have to
set up the processes and Define your
Sops you have to start implementing
compliant practices deploy a lamps for
data and quality management select an
accreditation body and apply for your
accreditation
then you have the stranger stuff for
internal and external audits perform an
internal audit address issue identified
in the internal authorities participate
in the external or a third party audit
to be useful you have to take corrective
action if they are suggested by the
Auditors and then you get a credit
question
what is ISO 2387 accreditation well as
we thought it was the important
regulatory standard
why to buy events needed well it
increased confidence with reliability
and boost efficiency how by advice can
follow it with is well it's very simple
the player lives and you can make
everything easier
so thank you very much for your time and
let's see if there are questions